this is very important
wang hao will be the one receiving draw
odds and they're off and uh this time
we are seeing
is it going to be
oh the queen's gambit declined catalan
again catalan
give a check
oh no bishop e7 how like specially seven
very classical he lost the game in the
candidates to anish one of the main
lines here with dc and a6
but magnus has played all kinds of goofy
moves here like knight to a3
trying to mix it
and uh speaking of uh mixing it is on
the board
yeah bishop d7 is supposed to be fight
for black
carlson won a game against anish and
vike so he probably has pleasant
memories i think he played this movie a4
and yeah now queen c2 or something
probably a3 first
not supposed to be anything
but magnus makes it something as always
we'll see
queen c2 on the board
yeah all of this was played against
anish knight bd7 looks like van gaal
even though it was during his retirement
saw that game and he's not particularly
surprised by carson's choice
ipd7 rook c1
i think they're still following that
game
but when did the invites for norway
chess go out
i'm not sure
you think
i think then before vikes so he started
watching vik thinking ah i might have to
play these guys again maybe
but uh
i think most of the top players they
keep their connection with the
yeah and the top games kind of kidding
i'm sure he followed yeah and
i also wasn't sure when we can ask him
one day
what the story with his retirement was
like
because first of all we've
talked already about that no one really
retires
and sometimes out of the emotion after a
bad tournament people say okay i'm done
with this stupid game
but they keep coming back
they keep getting off with one more
tournament and they're like all right
that
and the first tournament
as always like life has a way of kind of
keeping you hooked well chess has a way
of keeping you hooked to the game
i wonder if how after you get the call
from norway chess he told his family
just when i thought i was out
they pulled me back in
that's a quote from a movie but i don't
know which one i've had it before
godfather three
yeah
okay eddie one magnus not in a hurry
to regain this pawn
yeah
so uh
magnus feeling very comfortable there
because uh they say that the secret life
of a gambiter is to
win back the material you sacrificed
carson also playing with it playing with
the peace trick it seems like it's just
it's just what you do nowadays
yeah yeah it is the way to calm the
nerves apparently that's what i've
always done wrong
and uh wang hao just under five minutes
on the clock
and one how to make a decision
i mean there's there's no immediate
threat so you can just
go to 66
c6 is a little scary that this bishop
has nowhere to go but i guess the
argument is this bishop moves he takes
if this knight moves he takes the bishop
yeah so he doesn't need his bishop to
squares
there's also a kind of like knight e5
ideas on the board as you highlighted
yeah that looks like a normal movement
i guess he wants to take and
play some position like this
but
that's probably the best white can hope
for on this line we'll eventually
recapture
as the center
let's see if magnus agrees
if he lets go of that black bishop
what's happening
magnus just thinking
knight e5 looks very very natural is
there any other move to kind of play
instead of capturing the bishop i mean
e4 is just true looks a bit passive then
yeah b5 just comes nothing you got to go
95 so you can make b5 with taking on c6
he's done it
black should probably not take because
now all of a sudden yeah nice bishop not
having squares unless
unless you can set up some kind of
fantastic pawn chain but you're not
going to do that you need to get it well
you could try but i think even if you
got all this against the two bishops
why there's too much power fire power
power fire
yeah no i'm not gonna do that
so bishop takes bishop we
fully expect that to be played
and how does this b5 option at least the
computer seems to like it
it's just such a strange move to play
because you're allowing knight takes c6
takes takes
now the point is b4
giving up the rookie yeah he's taking on
g2 which looks much more human
now it's too late for b5 because then
knight c6 but is it possible to go queen
c7
okay so knight b6 is you predicted yeah
he's played knight b6
when seven was possible yeah and then i
just wanted to get b5
uh better k no
the knight just gets into d6 and
this is why you don't play b5
yeah this is still fairly standard but
magnus will be able to put a bit of
pressure here if he gets his pawn to e4
stopping the other knight from doing
anything active
he's taking a moment
yeah it's uh
but it feels like this is not a nice
position for wang hao
no
there's a lot of uncomfortable pressure
white has a center
e4 on the board
i think i probably would try to
move my knight back to d7 at night after
d7 and yeah that happened
okay
now he's going to take on c4
yeah there's some pressure
not
unbearable but
combined with the extra time still not a
bad situation
i'm wondering if he's thinking about
just going knight f3 nobody takes the
pawn
queen takes okay
so magnus no doubt has a fantastic
position i mean but is there any chance
for wang hao to set up
some kind of defensive formation because
yeah i don't think he's in too too much
trouble
um
so one thing i kind of wanted to do is
maybe f5 but
[Music]
they can't quite do it yet
knight
might have six i'm not sure because f3
is something white wanted anyway now
this knight seems a bit stuck here yeah
but why hasn't such a nice plan of just
putting a rook on b1 and putting the
bishop on
c5
yeah bishop c5 the knight comes back to
d7
okay damage is done yet
let's see how magnus handles it is queen
b3 awkward now because if rook b8 has an
e5 winning the exchange and yeah it's
played it
r d7 bishop c1
shuffling the piece around yeah full
board vision from magnus
and
does it achieve anything though like we
should have four queen c8
maybe we can target the a5 pawn later
maybe just go
h6
i'm i'm really stuck for a move and i
just know h6 looks normal make a left
stop bishop tree five
also make him move quickly yeah he has
to how much time does he have here just
under three minutes on the clock but the
bishop the thing is the bishop is coming
to f4 and then to e5 and again questions
will be asked to the knight on f6
and i just love the fact that the queen
is on the goldilocks third row you know
she can switch to
c5 he's trying to break free
oh
that is risky should f4
queen goes d takes c and the pawn might
be dropping
okay but maybe this is a good practical
idea
because the position did look quiet
horrible point is poor now
he wasn't in the mood to
wait passively for magnus to improve his
position
and it's always depends on the game ends
if you say
he should have waited passively or great
practical decision
very hard to say
yeah but it felt really really
unpleasant especially with uh the clock
ticking down at just under two minutes
and they are on with 24 so still away
from
the golden move which is at
440 and he's gone for
rook
c1 c5 b6 okay
i guess
sooner or later
i don't understand why didn't you take
on c5
mike's even better he takes c if what
takes
see what rook takes a queen takes maybe
queen takes
yeah
and then maybe still pressure not over
yet
yeah dc on the board
and
it's looking
great
for the world champion and now we're
expecting queen takes rook to a picture
if queen takes c5
then he wants to go after these pawns
here that's on the board
looks pretty good indeed
let's see six
i like queen b5 just
fix the weakness and uh good strategy
take them later yeah and look at that
girls
look at the black snipe the black knight
that just is out of play it's not f6 i
don't like because the knight can get
stuck here
now he has to fish for counter chances
but magnus
yeah queen seems very determined
queen two rugby two three it's not gonna
be a repetition today because the
king steps forward
to do its defensive duties and uh queen
takes porn
is gonna be the move
that wang hao has to meet and also
there could be there's a there's a
threat of
rook to b8
can you get no you can't get flashy not
yet
no it's still work
and uh wang how just under a minute
how to break through
i might have to take a step back i still
really want to exchange quits i think
all the end games with these fixed pawns
are more or less winning but um i was
not going to go along queen d3
trying to scare him here
but yeah
yeah maybe that's good
if queen c6 then we keep chasing queen
d6
i like that idea
i'm not going to lie though jan i was
not drawn to queen d3 i always look at
me as like g4
[Laughter]
yeah
but i like your move better
keep controlling sure about the
right version but this queen on c3 is
annoying so queen b3 or queen d3 but d3
feels better
and does the queen d3 is a magnus type
of move he wrote he realizes that the
end game is great
for white
winning because of the black the poor
position of the black knight
yeah the problems with queens on the
king is a little too loose so d6 or
something quick c2 there's always some
nagging counter play
um
he's taking his time though
yeah he has the time to take
and
i'm just wondering queen d3 plate
yep a nice uh
good practical shot
queen will probably step back
to
c6
yeah no if the end games offer any hope
now he goes back c7 and c8 yes
26 i'm assuming i know he takes oh
tactics bishop takes
rook takes queen d8
yeah so he does play like h6 but then
the queen side drops
i spot
oh sorry it's not bored here
takes b6
the point being if this gets taken
there are background issues
yeah that would be a little bit of a
disaster
so uh wang hao says nope not gonna fall
for that one today
seven
that's the problem
queen is seven
a second so wang hao has gone 11 seconds
he has uh it's 34 so it's got six
it's 11 seconds to make six moves
okay
living on the edge so queen d8 is going
to be met by the night retreat yep
important now
there's nothing attacked here so the
knight can just step in
yeah
and
white can just move the bishop and be
better
it's a good
it's a good thing to do
maybe make a surprising move move the
bishop to e
e3 keep the bishop close and
because he's probably ready with uh if
you play bishop d4 he's probably ready
with rook d8 or something like that
i'm starting to learn about your
strategy if in time travel shock them
and before they recover from the shock
exactly exactly they won't expect that
move never no
and also this is the kind of a good
safety first move
and
this is one thing i found sitting next
to david howell for over a year that uh
when you're
feeling
under the time pressure you have to kind
of curl up into a little ball over
protect and start making commitments
when you've passed the time control
limit which is a move 40 and then you
can think a little bit more with your
lovely one second increment
so magnus now
coming to one minute on the clock
but okay it's also a good strategy right
yes make the opponent sit there and wait
and queen d4 played so that was the
surprising h6 and bishop takes pawn now
there's no longer
any checks on a7 yeah
well done
he's uh he's made it to move 36. he has
eight seconds for the remainder so i'm
predicting king to g2 yep covering the
h1 square and how's going for
a desperate counter-attack he's lost
long-term with the two missing pawns of
course
and carlson's trying to tape can
keep control and
they've reached move 39
so 1005 seconds oh but this is it no
castle is forcing the end game
and the a pawns will queen
so the world champion wins his
armageddon game